تجري الليلة عملية بحث وإنقاذ عاجلة
في شمال
المحيط الأطلسي في المنطقة القريبة من حطام
سفينة تيتانيك للعثور على غواصة مفقودة وعلى
متنها خمسة أشخاص،
وقال خفر السواحل الأمريكي لشبكة CNN إن هناك سفينة في
مكان الحادث وطائرة من بينها C-130
الطائرات والسفن والطائرات الكندية التي تنضم إلى
البحث بالإضافة إلى
المطبوعات القطبية للسفينة التي نقلت
الغواصة المفقودة إلى موقع حطام تيتانيك على بعد حوالي 380 ميلاً قبالة
ساحل نيوفاوندلاند، ويقول خفر السواحل إن
السفينة غرقت
صباح الأحد وفقدت الاتصال  مع وجود طاقم
The Polar Prince بعد ساعة و45
دقيقة من هبوطه، يتعين علينا
التأكد من أننا نبحث على
السطح باستخدام السفن الجوية والسطحية
ولكن بعد ذلك نتوسع في
البحث تحت الماء أيضًا، في الوقت الحالي
تقتصر قدرتنا على  أه عوامات السونار
والاستماع للأصوات ولكنك تعلم أننا
نعمل بجد لزيادة
القدرة على أن هذا الإنقاذ يمثل سباقًا ضد شركة
Ocean Gate Expeditions على موقعها الإلكتروني،
الشركة التي تشغل
الغواصة في الرحلات الاستكشافية وصولاً إلى
تيتانيك، تقول السفينة التي يبلغ طولها 21 قدمًا  تحتوي على ما يصل
إلى 96 ساعة من الأكسجين لمدة أربعة أيام لخمسة
أشخاص، إشارة واحدة يمكن أن يبحث عنها رجال الإنقاذ، هل تحتوي على
أي من القطع العادية للوحدة
مثل هذه الغواصة؟
إشارة إلى الخطأ الذي يمكن أن
يحدث، يقول فريق الطقس في CNN إن
الطقس في المنطقة لم يكن قاسياً للغاية
في الوقت الذي غمرت فيه السفينة، لكن
الخبراء يقولون إن التيارات الموجودة تحت السطح
يمكن أن تؤثر على الغواصة أو
مع محركاتها ومراوحها المختلفة،
يمكن أن تكون محاصرة.  من السهل جدًا
أن تعلق فجأة بشيء ما
ولا يمكنها العودة إلى السطح.
غرقت تيتانيك عام 1912 بعد اصطدامها
بجبل جليدي مما أدى إلى مقتل أكثر من 1500 شخص،
تم اكتشاف الحطام عام 1985 مقسمًا
إلى قسمين مؤخرًا
مشروع مسح تحت الماء باستخدام  خلق رسم خرائط أعماق البحار
صورًا مذهلة جديدة
للسفينة، وأصبحت
وجهة سياحية شهيرة ومكلفة، حيث تكلف الرحلة مائتين
وخمسين ألف دولار للشخص الواحد
للقيام برحلة إلى تيتانيك على
غواصة تيتان التي تفتقد الآن
تيتانيك التي تقع على ارتفاع حوالي 12500 قدم.
أكثر من ميلين تحت السطح، وهو العمق
الذي يقول الخبراء إنه يعقد أي
مهمة إنقاذ، إنه كوكب مختلف، إنه
كوكب مختلف تمامًا، يمكنك الانتقال من
عالم الشمس الذي نعرفه إلى
الأسفل من خلال ما نسميه
منطقة الشفق حيث ذلك الحضن الجميل الأزرق
يتحول إلى اللون الأزرق الغامق الأزرق الداكن ثم
تظل في حالة من السواد لمدة ساعتين ويؤدي
الضغط ببطء إلى زيادة حرارة
الشمس وتتلاشى ويبدأ برودة أعماق المحيط في
التسلل إلى الغواصة،
نبدأ بعملية بحث
وإنقاذ عاجلة  العملية الجارية
حاليًا في المحيط الأطلسي
يتسابق مسؤولو خفر السواحل الأمريكي للعثور على
غواصة تديرها شركة
تدير جولات لحطام تيتانيك،
ويقول المسؤولون إنه تم الإبلاغ عن
تأخر هذه العملية يوم الأحد ويقال إنها لم تستغرق سوى
96 ساعة فقط.  وقت البقاء قيل لنا أن
العديد من الوكالات الحكومية وشركات
أعماق البحار تعمل على
إعادة الاتصال بهذه
الغواصة ميغيل ماركيز من CNN
ينضم إلينا الآن على الهواء مباشرة مع مزيد من التفاصيل حول
ميغيل هذا، ماذا تعرف في هذه
المرحلة
نعم الشركة التي تدير هذه
العملية  تقوم Ocean Gate Expeditions
بكل شيء بدءًا من العلوم
تحت الماء وحتى التصوير الفوتوغرافي والفيديو
إلى السياحة وكذلك إلى أماكن مثل
حطام السفينة تيتانيك وقد فعلت ذلك
لبعض الوقت وتكلف حوالي 250000 جنيه إسترليني
للشخص الواحد للقيام بهذا ما لا نفعله.  أعرف
بالضبط من كان على هذه الغواصة،
يمكنها استيعاب ما إذا كان هذا هو الشخص
المعروض على موقعهم على الإنترنت، يمكنها استيعاب ما يصل
إلى خمسة أشخاص، لديها ما يعادل 96 ساعة من
الهواء، لكن كل هذا يتوقف على عدد
الأشخاص الموجودين على تلك الغواصة و  ما مدى
العمق الذي نعرفه أن خفر السواحل الأمريكي جنبًا إلى
جنب مع القوات الجوية الكندية
يساعدون في هذا، فهم جميعًا
يتحركون نحو هذه المنطقة بأجنحة ثابتة
وقوارب تحاول الوصول إلى المنطقة حتى
يتمكنوا من المساعدة ولكن انظر إلى هذا
بعيدة للغاية، هذه الأعماق
عميقة بشكل لا يصدق، تيتانيك نفسها تبلغ
حوالي 3800 متر أي حوالي 13000
قدم تحت سطح المحيط، وهي بعيدة
للغاية وصعبة
التشغيل في يوم جيد،
الكنديون لديهم طائرة P8 أو
طائرة بوسيدون  التي لديها بعض
القدرة على الرؤية بشكل أساسي تحت الماء، إنها
طائرة صيد فرعية يمكنها الرؤية
تحت الماء إلى حد ما ولكن ليس من
الواضح
ما إذا كانوا يعرفون مكان هذه المركبة وما
حدث لها بالضبط
كما ذكرت لديهم  96
ساعة من الهواء في ظروف مثالية نوعًا ما،
لكن ليس من الواضح نظرًا لأنه
تم الإبلاغ عن فقدان هذه المركبة منذ 24 ساعة،
والآن ما مقدار الهواء الذي قد يكون لديهم ومن
أين يبدأ هذا البحث الآن،
كل الأيدي العاملة على سطح السفينة تحاول
العثور على هذه المركبة برينا
حسنًا، ميغيل، شكرًا لك على
آخر الأخبار هناك، أريد أن أتحول الآن إلى
خبير في هذا الأمر، لدينا بوتش هندريك
معنا هنا، ولكن لديك 30 عامًا من
الخبرة كغواص إنقاذ، وأنت أيضًا
رئيس ومؤسس
أنظمة الإنقاذ  وهي
شركة دولية للتدريب على الإنقاذ والاسترداد، هل
تعرف من أين تبدأ بعملية إنقاذ مثل
هذه؟
أعتقد أنه بنفس الطريقة التي سيعمل بها
خفر السواحل الأمريكي والكنديون،
أول شيء هو
اكتشاف ما
إذا كانت الوحدة الغاطسة
قابلة للتحرير  منارات، منارات للطوارئ، لذا
إذا حدث ذلك، فمن المحتمل أن يتم
إطلاق منارة أو اثنتين على السطح
حتى يمكن تعقبها،
وستخرج إشارة من
خفر السواحل المظلم،
وسيتمكن الكنديون والبريطانيون من التقاطها و  ثم
نكون قادرين على البدء في تتبع
المكان الذي قد يأتي منه،
وسننظر إلى ما حدث في آخر
48 ساعة للطقس، وما هي الظروف التي
ربما تغيرت والتي ليست طبيعية،
وما الذي كان سيحدث مع
التيارات في الأعماق و  بين
القاع على ارتفاع يزيد عن 12000 قدم
ويمكن أن يحدث السطح
ويتجاوز فجأة قوة الوحدة، وستكون الغاطسة في
الأسفل بعد ذلك هي أن
الوحدة الغاطسة المناسبة يجب أن تحتوي على
منارة أو اثنتين يمكن ربطها
بها  يمكن أن يرسل ذلك
إشارة تحت الماء تخبر الناس
بكيفية العثور عليها،
لذا سأبحث عن أولئك الذين يراقبون
الطقس ويتتبعون ما
كان سيحدث لو تم نقلها من
الموقع، ومن المؤكد أن خفر السواحل سيفعلون ذلك.
يفعلون شيئًا مشابهًا جدًا
وسيأتون
بأجهزة التتبع الخاصة بهم إذا عثروا على منارة تم
إطلاقها من الغواصة،
فسيرون مكانها ويتتبعون الطقس ويضعون جهازًا
آخر خاصًا بهم في الماء
ويتتبعونه ويرون كيف  سوف تذهب وأين
ستكون الاحتمالات